the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones and a
song of ice and fire video all right my
friends in this video i will be giving
my thoughts on one of the major scenes
that was left out of game of thrones
now as you all know game of thrones was
adapted from george rr martin's epic
fantasy saga a song of ice and fire when
hbo started developing game of thrones
for television george rr martin was
actually still writing the novels as far
as i know this doesn't happen very often
most things are adapted from works that
are already finished now unfortunately
hbo started releasing seasons of game of
thrones before it even had an ending
george rr martin as well as hbo was
hoping he would finish his novels long
before game of thrones reached its final
season
back when hbo released its first season
of game of thrones in 2011 george had
already written 5 very large books
however this still wasn't enough for
many years now george rr martin has said
he would need to write at least seven
books to finish his story unfortunately
he hasn't released another book in the
song of ice and fire saga in over a
decade game of thrones would eventually
end after eight seasons without george
finishing another book this meant that
the game of thrones writers david and
dan would have to create a lot of their
own scenes to finish the show and as you
all know that's exactly what they did
not only did they write a lot of their
own scenes but they also deviated from a
lot of george rr martin's original ideas
i've made several videos about this
before the game of thrones writers left
out a lot of amazing scenes and moments
from a song of ice and fire one of these
scenes was actually set up in the very
last episode written by george rr martin
now for those of you that don't know
george rr martin wrote some of the
episodes for game of thrones he actually
wrote one episode for each of the first
four seasons of the show the very last
episode he wrote was the lion and the
rose the episode famously known for
joffrey's wedding now what's really
interesting about this episode is you
can go online and read an early version
of this script written by george rr
martin this early draft of the lion in
the rose differs wildly from what ended
up airing on hbo and what makes this
even more interesting are some of the
notes george r martin left for writers
david and dan
one of these notes actually reveals a
scene that will happen in the winds of
winter the author was hoping they would
show it on game of thrones in one of the
later seasons but they never did so as
of right now the scene still hasn't
happened in any format let me show you
what his note says it says a note for
future reference a season or two down
the line ramsay's pack of wolfhounds are
going to be sent against the stark
direwolves so we should build up the
dogs as much as possible in this in
subsequent episodes the reason why he
left this note here is because of the
opening scene in the episode the very
first scene in the last episode written
by george rr martin showed ramsay
sending his hounds after one of the
girls he was abusing in winterfell
she thinks she's pretty
let me put one through her face
you have to reward the hounds
they did all the hard work
but you made miranda feel jealous be
jealous of her
as you can see by the note george was
setting up the hounds for a much larger
scene down the road eventually he would
have all of them face off against the
stark direwolves now if i just look at
the scene on its surface level the
little boy inside of me thinks this
sounds awesome who doesn't want to see
ramsay's hounds fight against the stark
direwolves that would be amazing
especially in the show format because
you could actually see it but then i
also think about what this could mean
for the song of ice and fire novels this
makes me wonder how and when this will
happen because everything that is
happening in the books is not set up the
same way it was in the show
now as i said before the last book that
was released was a dance with dragons at
the end of that book ramsay still has
winterfell him and stannis will most
likely have their battle near the
beginning of the next book the winds of
winter now unlike the show ramsay did
not marry sansa he married one of her
friends jane in the books sansa's not
even there she's still in the veil the
rest of the starks are still scattered
all over westeros and even essos so if
even some of the starks will be there
for the battle it will have to happen
much later sansa's direwolf lady is dead
just like she was in the show
rob and greywind are dead just like it
happened in the show jon is still dead
but him and ghost are at the wall
together summer and bran are still in
bloodraven's cave out beyond the wall
rickon and shaggy dog are somewhere in
skagos andaria is still an esos however
nymeria is somewhere roaming around the
riverlands if you look at george's note
again it sounds like there will be more
than one direwolf there to fight
ramsay's hounds and i do wonder which
ones it will be as you all know in game
of thrones they had jon rickon and sansa
there for the battle of the bastards so
maybe we'll only see ghost and shaggy
dog fight ramsay sounds that is if the
battle unfolds the same way it did in
the show which i don't think it will
first ramsay will have to face off
against dennis baratheon and all of his
men now there's actually a lot of fans
who think stannis will win that battle
so let's say stannis does win the battle
how would we get this fight against the
hounds and the dire wolves then well
maybe stannis wins but he doesn't get
winterfell right away maybe the starks
will have to help him finish off ramsay
then we will get this scene or maybe
stannis wins but ramsay doesn't die
for some reason i feel like ramsay has
to be alive for his hounds to fight the
stark's direwolves but i guess it isn't
necessary although i think it would make
for a much better scene if he was there
maybe stannis wins and gets winterfell
but ramsay doesn't die i guess he could
always go on the run or to another
castle where the stark saying their
direwolves could face off against him
then however i'm not so sure stannis
will win that battle now i don't think
he will die like he did in the show
maybe he loses the first battle and
that's when the starks join him later
for a second battle or maybe stannis
does meet the same fate he did in game
of thrones then some of the starks could
reunite and force ramsay out of their
home one way or another what i love so
much about this one little note is there
are so many different scenarios that
could unfold there is one other option i
should mention because george rr martin
has hinted at something else happening
that does involve our furry four-legged
friends in one of george r martin's many
interviews he once said you know i don't
like to give things away but you don't
hang a giant wolf pack on the wall
unless you intend to use it this has
always made me wonder when we will see
this as well i can't help but wonder if
this is what he means when he says
ramsay sounds will face the dire wolves
of house stark now when it comes to
nymeria and her pack of wolves she is
obviously the only one of house stark
but depending on how things unfold you
never know if all of them will end up
following arya before the end maybe he
will have arya and nymeria reunite sort
of like they did in the show only they
could have a much larger role in the
books regardless of the scenario i hope
we see ramsay and his hounds suffer a
vicious defeat at the hands of hal stark
let me know what your thoughts are about
the scene left out of game of thrones
and also let me know how you think it
will happen in the books will ramsay
still have winterfell when this happens
and if so what does that mean for
stannis the manas as always i want to
thank each and every one of you for
watching my video i hope you all have a
great day i'll see you soon bye
[Music]
you